good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 650 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 650 is to be stored in a lockable
room at least 4 meters by 4 meters with
comfortable lighting it must remain
under constant surveillance by no less
than 3 personnel observers are to
position themselves so that the SCP and
at least one additional observer are in
their line of sight at all times
observation via remote methods such as
security cameras is permissible so long
as concentration is not broken at any
time this method should only be used in
case of emergency however due to the
possibility of accidental loss of sight
[Music]
description SCP 650 is a black statue of
a stylized humanoid 167 centimeters tall
the statue does not possess hands or
facial features the limbs taper off into
rounded points and the head is a smooth
surface all round the default posture
while under observation as the statue
reaching upwards head tilted as if
facing the sky composition of the statue
is currently undetermined materials
testing has yielded inconclusive and
contradictory results if the statue is
not being observed it will relocate
itself to a point immediately behind
whomever is in the containment site and
assume a threatening posture no noise is
made during this relocation process so
the precise method of locomotion is as
of yet unknown the relocation point and
posture are typically close enough to
induce an automatic fight-or-flight
response in the observer once they turn
around and see it however it should be
noted that the SCP has not yet shown any
signs of active aggression or hostility
based on trial responses that varied the
amount of time between breaking and
re-establishing line-of-sight its
purpose does not seem to be attack but
merely to startle the reason for this is
unknown and no further research is
pending to determine its motives while
the primary method appears to be
triggering a startled reaction by a
close proximity the SCP has also shown
varied other postures in the presence of
observers who have become used to its
effects in the cases of these observers
the statue has assumed other postures a
comfortable distance away including
reclining on a table sitting on a chair
and in one instance huddled in a corner
as if terrified given that the observers
who reported these postures also
mentioned that they were left feeling
uneasy it is theorized that this may
simply be a secondary method of
generating reactions
addendum object upgraded to Euclid class
after Statue somehow managed to appear
on the other side of site and manifest
directly behind dr. in his office
additional observational measures are to
be put in place to prevent future
incidents researchers note I don't give
a flying rat about the budget keep this
damn thing contained turning around in a
Dem office to see this thing a half inch
away from your nose is guaranteed to
take years from your life and given what
we deal with we don't have any time to
spare dr. P okay that about does it for
today thank you very much for listening
and you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bashert Muslim Mookie Jax
Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin Thomas
Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter Cody tench
Tiber ball on sy7 actual if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volume thank you
you